[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so when these new Macbook Pros got
announced my first thought was huh I
wonder if we can retire the travel iMac
because some of you might not know this
but whenever I'd go for the past couple
years to a tech event that I planned on
making a video at I literally packed up
a maxed out iMac Pro put it in a huge
Pelican case and lugged it with me like
there's countless times y'all would
catch me rolling this huge box behind me
through the airport and that's because
it's been the smallest machine that I
could take with me to one of those
events that could render and edit and
Export a video that wouldn't take
overnight now this apple silicon
transition from Max has been pretty
impressive and I think this is the first
time I can truly say something is
actually next level
these laptops have been Next Level so
these are the new 14 inch and 16 inch
2021 MacBook Pros and they're incredible
for a number of reasons now at the end
of the day they're just tools used to
get a job done and the fact is everyone
has a slightly different thing that they
want to get done for me it's making
these videos so we'll get to that in a
second but man they have made a big jump
both on the inside and the outside of
these laptops so let's start on the
outside so these laptops have a new
top-notch design it still looks like a
MacBook Pro but I like pretty much all
the changes they've made so the whole
shape is squared off a bit and it
resembles those old aluminum power books
just more modernized and just
aesthetically you can see they've made
these laptops thicker like noticeably
thicker and that is totally fine with me
and it has plenty of benefits and it
also stands up a little bit higher on
those taller feet which seemingly gives
it a bit more room for those back and
side vents for better ventilation
although I've never heard the fans spin
up audibly on these laptops the Apple
logo on the back slightly larger and
there's a little engraving at the bottom
now where they carved in the MacBook Pro
text that's kind of nice but
functionally as you've probably noticed
yeah there's ports now there are real
ports and this really shouldn't be a big
deal but this is one of the few things
that Apple has actually walked back from
the last few years of MacBook Pros that
haven't had these ports so while it
feels like kind of silly to celebrate
them
I am happy that they're back so on the
right side that's a full-size HDMI port
welcome back then you have one of the
Thunderbolt 4 ports and a full-size half
depth SD card slot this is beautiful I
use an SD card for audio every time I
make a video I use them all the time and
it's been a long time since I just
plugged an SD card straight into a
computer so this is fun then around the
left side you have two more Thunderbolt
4 ports a headphone jack and the
Magnetic magsafe charging port has made
its return so okay a couple thoughts on
this port selection first of all magsafe
has made its return but it's different
I've never used a magsafe machine full
time in the past but this is a newer
thinner and actually stronger magsafe
it's got a lot more lateral strength
that it takes to pull it out of the
machine so the second there's any angle
on it it snaps out much easier but still
feels pretty mag safe to me definitely
safer than just if USBC was plugged
straight in and then you get this huge
charging brick so this is the 96 watt
power adapter that comes with the 14
inch MacBook Pro which is already an
upgrade from the 60 7 watt of the base
model and then there's this huge
rectangular 140 watt charging brick for
the 16 inch MacBook Pro but it is pretty
nice that the brick is separate from the
braided USBC cable with magsafe on the
other end but I am not sure why the
space gray laptop doesn't also come with
a space gray magsafe connector that
would have been a nice touch 140 Watts
though that is a lot of power and so you
can fast charge these laptops through
magsafe if you want to it's about half
charge in half an hour which is pretty
convenient but even if you don't want to
you can unplug and just plug in via USB
C if you're a one charger for everything
kind of person like me it'll still be
about 96 Watts so not as fast but still
pretty good now the headphone jack
and you might have caught during Apple's
presentation that they mentioned that
the headphone jack this time would
support High impedance headphones what
does that mean
well if you have to ask it probably
doesn't apply to you but there's a whole
ecosystem of headphones out there with
much higher levels of power required to
get real volume out of them they're
known as high impedance headphones I've
got a couple pairs here at the studio so
a normal pair of wired headphones just
think about like your Beats or ath m50s
might have 20 to 50 ohms impedance the
high impedance headphones can go well
over 100 ohms and so they won't really
sound like much they'll be very low in
volume if you plug them into almost
anything with a headphone jack and so
people who use these headphones will
have to carry an external Thunderbolt
DAC just a little thing to plug in and
so if these headphone Jacks are high
powered enough in theory that's one less
dongle you have to carry right so for my
audio files out there the preamps here
are impressive and they're definitely
pushing out more power but this isn't
some incredible super clean DAC or
anything crazy with the these bear
Dynamic dt770 Pros for example which are
250 ohm headphones MacBook Pro M1 at
absolutely maxed out 100 volume sounded
comfortable and these new Macbook Pros
hit that same level at about 65 volume
so there was an improvement they don't
sound better than the dedicated amp you
would have to bring but in a pinch if
you've only brought one pair of
headphones you can plug them in straight
and that's kind of neat which is just
saving you a dongle and that's kind of
the theme of all of these ports to be
honest like the HDMI port is only
actually HDMI 2.0 not 2.1 I don't know
why and it's kind of annoying that's
such an expensive computer doesn't have
the latest highest end part but HDMI 2.0
still does 4K 60 so it's great for any
projector TV it's good to pinch one less
dongle the SD card slot is xdxc it's
only UHS two speeds so it doesn't
support the newer faster uh S3 but UHS 2
is still 300 megabytes per second that's
pretty good in a pinch one less dongle
so it's an expensive computer it I could
have easily had the higher end ports
it's definitely a knock on them but like
I said it's kind of just like the
convenient in a pinch type thing and you
know what I might as well since we're
talking ports you know it would have
been cool ethernet on the power brick
remember what they did with the M1 iMac
where they have like gigabit Ethernet
built into the brick I think MacBook Pro
users would be more likely to want
ethernet without a dongle on the laptop
like they did here but they didn't but
anyway there's just something hilarious
about them going backwards on the last
four years of MacBook Pros and actually
adding ports back to it it's not
something they do all the time so I'm
giving a thumbs up on that
speaking of going backwards though
no touch bar so there's a new keyboard
on these MacBook Pros and it's all
buttons all real physical keys so
they've replaced the touch bar with a
full row of full height physical
function keys at the top it's really a
shame the touch bar never reached its
full potential and I'll miss the like
two times I thought it was useful with
audio fading shortcuts inside Final Cut
Pro or fast forwarding scrubbing through
Instagram videos on the desktop but
these buttons really are better and the
whole keyboard is an improvement from
previous years too it's backlit the keys
feel good and travel decently well like
their keyboards from five years ago the
touch ID button in the corner Works
super quickly and reliably and it's
subtle but the whole keyboard is in set
in this black anodized rectangle and I
love it it's a nice touch Black Keys
will definitely still show fingerprints
and a little bit of skin oils more than
the lighter keyboards out there on other
machines but I'm willing to deal with
that the speakers
absolutely incredible especially on the
16 inch still the biggest fullest best
speakers I've ever heard in a laptop on
the bigger one and the studio
microphones are also now improved but
that brings us to uh the front of this
laptop so let's talk about the front so
these new displays are on paper and in
real life pretty incredible they are
10-bit panels they're mini LED HDR 16 by
10 almost 4K High refresh rate displays
I mean it's just all the boxes checked
and then there's the notch up top
okay so the screens are amazing it's
basically a Mini Pro display xdr but
with even higher pixel density and
higher refresh rate I mean it doesn't
look that different from previous
MacBook Pros most of the time you're
using it but it does hit that 1600 nits
Max brightness while watching HDR
content which is awesome and the thinner
bezels all the way around were long
overdue and underneath the menu bar I'm
also happy that it is still it's the
taller 16 by 10 aspect ratio and then
promotion is interesting so we know this
is the Adaptive refresh rate it's not
always maxing out here at 120 hertz even
when flying around the UI you know Macs
were already decently smooth at 60 but I
can tell this is not going to 120 hertz
all the time so like scrolling in Safari
for example apparently Safari still
needs an update to support the highest
of this adaptive frame rate but there
are a couple areas where you really
notice a higher refresh rate I mean
moving your mouse around a lot moving a
lot of bigger animations like swiping
between spaces and other big flowy stuff
like the genie animation for minimizing
that stuff I mean it's awesome moving
around a final cut timeline that's very
smooth too that's where the higher frame
rate is noticeable and the extra
smoothness is appreciated so this isn't
the first mini LED display this isn't
the first HDR laptop ever it's
definitely not the first higher
frustrated screen in a laptop but just
combining all these things the 10-bit
display the thinner bezels all of it it
is a great display
so let's talk about the top-notch design
shall we there's only a few things up
here in the notch it's the new 1080p
webcam which looks perfectly decent now
thanks for catching up Apple and there's
a little ambient light sensor and a
little LED light and that's pretty much
it there's no way the notch needed to be
this big for that Hardware I mean I'll
wait for the iFix to tear down but
there's no way you needed this much
space so it's an odd choice and it's
really easy to complain about this when
you're not actually using the laptop but
two things one I think apple is actually
finding this to be like a part of their
design language now like this is a
recognizable laptop silhouette because
of the notch
however we feel about that it is what it
is but then also turns out it's okay to
put a notch right here in the part of
the screen that you really don't notice
very much
when you're actually using the laptop
the mouse goes underneath it for those
who are wondering and the software seems
to basically treat the screen like there
is no Notch like if you take a
screenshot or do a screen recording it's
still drawing the display there with all
of its pixels and anytime you go full
screen with anything it just turns the
entire menu bar black and it looks like
the bezel at the top basically gets
slightly thicker and it's very deep
black with the mini LED the notch
literally never cuts into any content
basically think of it as cutting into
the extra display that you actually
didn't have before and they've just
shoved the menu bar up there into that
extra display you know there are some
weird quirks when you have an app with
enough menu bar items it runs those
things right underneath the Notch and
things clearly need to be patched up
with a software update maybe making them
scrollable or like adding an expansion
button or something like that so at this
point it's like oh people are making the
you know custom apps to totally black
out the top part of the display to hide
the notch which
I mean if you hate it that much sure you
have that option but like I promise you
when you actually start using the laptop
and you're in apps and things full
screen and never Cuts anything off like
you're paying attention to what's on the
screen
it disappears even more than it did on
the smaller screen of the phones but
that being said if the next version of
this laptop still has a notch this big
and doesn't add face ID
I'll wear socks and sandals for a day
like Linus like they got to be planning
on putting it there eventually right it
almost feels useless to talk about how
it feels just spinning around Mac OS
Monterey because of course it's fine
like I got the improved notification
management it's got the rounded Corners
up top it's got the quick Mouse over at
the bottom corner to get to Quick notes
we get all that those nice features but
we're here for the performance we want
to know if it's actually as great as
those graphs Apple suggested at the
Apple event spoiler alert they're both
really that good so I've got a couple
different specs here this is the M1 Pro
in the 14 inch I've also got a maxed out
16 inch that I've been testing so I'll
get to the differences between M1 Max
and M1 Pro and all that in a second but
just know that yeah they are very very
good so when it comes to Performance
benchmarks I feel like everyone's more
or less looking for the perfect
Benchmark out there that will confirm to
them that it will work best for their
own workflow like I said these are tools
and from what I've seen it feels like
that Benchmark result exists for pretty
much every use case so far for these so
as far as synthetic benchmarks it
dropped the highest single score
geekbench CPU score I've ever seen from
any Mac and multi-core lined it up right
around the maxed out 18 core iMac I also
ran it through cinebench and it had
again very impressive single core scores
and here's how the multi-core stacks up
but when I say when I tell you these
laptops are next level
I mean that because these the the real
world performance and the real world
capabilities of these laptops is
dramatically better than they have any
business doing so obviously we know
about the way higher memory bandwidth we
know about the way higher number of GPU
cores and I love the 10 15 25
improvements that come across the board
with all that stuff the vertical
integration worked right but there are
parts of this chip that Apple has built
with specific purposes in mind and for
those purposes
it's next level so these laptop chips
have a media engine and there's a prores
accelerator as part of that M1 Max has
two of them video professionals you can
see where we're going with this working
with prores at all with these laptops is
dramatically better I think an example
was like encoding a video with
compressor is 10 times as fast as it was
with the Intel MacBook Pros
that's the next level so like I said
these laptops are that's why they got me
excited I work with video too so let's
see how it does with Final Cut Pro so as
I mentioned I did edit the last video
the entire airpods through review on the
16 inch M1 Max MacBook Pro in various
locations both around the studio and at
home plugged in and on battery and it
handled it incredibly well like
shockingly well keep in mind this is 8k
red code raw footage it's a mix of low
and medium compression shots from the V
Raptor and I'm able to bend the color
and raw data and move all around the
timeline and chop everything up pretty
quickly and seamlessly without hiccups
just like on the desktop on the Mac Pro
so playback was in high quality instead
of high performance so I'm getting a ton
of resolution and really only dropping a
couple of frames here and there again
just like the Mac Pro one of my ways to
measure if a machine is choking or
struggling at all is like how long the
delay is between pressing the play
button the space bar on on unrendered
footage and when it actually starts to
play back
and this delay as you can see it's like
less than a quarter of a second that's
as good as I've ever seen it in Final
Cut so the only thing that's caused me
any concern was that a couple times the
audio waveform previews took longer to
load when I was pinching and zooming
into parts of the timeline and I suspect
that's Ram related of course M1 Max only
has 64 gigs of ram versus the Mac Pro
I've edited on has 768 gigs of RAM so it
makes sense that I saw a difference
there but when the edit was finished and
it came time to export it I of course
just for fun copy the project across to
multiple computers and just did the same
export on all of them to see how it went
so the M1 Pro MacBook Pro the 14 inch
exported the whole thing in 6 minutes
and 40 seconds it's pretty good the 50
000 28 core Mac Pro
did the same thing in five minutes and
42 seconds and then the M1 Max Mac Pro
or MacBook Pro
did it in four minutes
and six seconds
so the MacBook Pro beat the Mac Pro
handily at exporting the project and
it's not even like export Times Really
Matter all that much at this level four
minutes five minutes whatever but the
fact that it beat the Mac Pro already is
ridiculous and I also did that while not
plugged in which doesn't lose any
performance on battery and the battery
dropped two percent from 96 to 94 while
exporting so you might have heard
there's different performance profiles
and this is true on the 16-inch MacBook
Pro was interesting playing with these
most of the time I just left it on
automatic because it would just do its
thing no hiccups at all and I could edit
fine but when I went to go export just
for fun I turned on the 16 inches high
power mode which in theory should let
the chips run Full Throttle more often
spin up the fans a little bit more Etc I
still never heard the fans ever but the
export time was even faster three
minutes and 49 seconds Jesus and on top
of all that the plug-in Suite that I use
motion VFX is updating steadily all
their stuff to support apple silicon
which is great at this point honestly I
think it's a no-brainer the travel iMac
is now retired
I can safely edit everything on a laptop
but Final Cut Pro is just one use case
there's plenty of other stuff if you
watch the verge's review they did a lot
of adobe stuff you can check out their
incredible findings with the newest
version of After Effects really finally
taking advantage of multi-threaded GPU
rendering they also showed it
outperforming the mobile RTX 3080 when
editing in Premiere there are some
glowing reviews from music producers and
sound designers who love having a
whisper silent computer that can also
process way more audio effects and that
they can take with them and Tyler
stallman did a great video reviewing the
laptop for photographers where the M1
Max laptop is importing and generating
previews Etc twice as fast as a 2018
MacBook Pro and he also opens up every
single app at once and streams a bunch
of prores videos all simultaneously next
to each other and you guessed it it
doesn't even blink then there's also a
great tweet from a staff engineer at
Reddit the machine is cutting build
times for their Android app in half and
a little napkin math says that buying a
team of them a bunch of these laptops
would end up saving them a lot more
money than they'd spend basically these
experiences are of course all dependent
on the apps you use as a professional
and how optimized they are all of
Apple's apps are the first ones to be
updated right out the box so Final Cut
Pro that I use is great but over time
more of them will continue to be updated
and see those gains as well and I didn't
even talk about battery life but it does
all this high performance stuff while
also being incredibly efficient so you
have the fast charging already if you
want it but I found that the 16 inch
with the 100 watt hour battery lasts a
bit longer than the 14 inch with a 70
watt hour battery and M1 Pro will last a
bit longer than M1 Max turns out those
GPU cores do run a little bit hotter and
use more power but ultimately if you
want the longest possible battery life
that would be 16 inch M1 Pro
nevertheless they all get around the
same battery life I found as the M1
MacBook Pro which is to say all day Best
in Class
ah you can still kill it in like four
hours if you're just sitting on battery
editing video in high power mode the
whole time then yeah then you can crush
it but again the fast charging turns out
to be very useful so you know what
here's the recommendation if you are a
professional that works on your laptop
and you're on an older version or you
find yourself reaching the limits of one
of these and you're thinking maybe you
should try to look at one of these new
Macbook Pros
I feel very confident saying yeah you
could pick one up and be very very happy
I think the real choice is between M1
Pro and M1 Max and 14 inch and 16 inch
now for me I'm going with a 16 inch M1
Max just because I take advantage of the
extra GPU cores and I wish I could go
with the 14 inch maxed out which you can
max out to the same exact specs as a 16
inch with maybe just small thermal
differences they'll perform about the
same but I really like having the bigger
screen for editing video so I'm going
maxed out big laptop so then for M1 Pro
versus M1 Max M1 Max is the most
powerful but it does Nick a bit of your
battery life so I would upgrade only if
you need those extra GPU cores and
you'll know if your apps support it and
I won't even pretend to game on a Mac
some people do though and if you do
theoretically the M1 Max would also
handle that better but like I said from
the beginning this is a tool and it
happens to be a really really good tool
at what it does and it happens to be
next level at a couple specific things
that it's been designed and optimized
for so there's going to be a lot of
professionals like me who are really
happy with these there's also going to
be a lot of people who totally don't
need this power but just have a lot of
money to spend and just want to get a
nice laptop and it is a nice laptop so I
wouldn't blame you that's fine too but
I'm just happy I can finally say that
this is I will be editing videos on a
laptop which is that's awesome and uh
yeah I haven't been able to say
something's truly next level in a really
long time
but these are it's one of my favorite
products of the year to be honest
I also really really can't wait until
the Apple silicon Mac Pro desktop that
thing's going to be wild
either way that's been it for the review
of the laptops thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one peace